[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance we no longer have a president
of the United States we have an
executive for dismissing facts he
doesn't like and believing lies he does
we have a head of state of paranoia we
have a conspiracy peddler in chief there
are positives underlying this insanity
few but potent such a damaged
personality cannot discern that while
every new false who had made bind to him
more tightly those who already trust him
that they also inevitably drive more
people away such a narcissist cannot
realize that every time he invokes
Russia and close ties and wiretaps and
the intelligence services and
investigations he does not decrease he
only increases the chances that the
investigations by the intelligence
services of the close ties to Russia
will not be about others but will be
about him and such a messianic
individual cannot fathom that his rumor
mongering is so dangerous merely to
himself that even the director of the
FBI feels compelled to publicly get out
his conclusion that Trump is lying
but these positives still sit under a
pile of excrement of radioactive waste
of what even a Republican senator
correctly describes as a quote
civilization warping crisis of public
trust the immediacy of such a danger the
active crisis of fantasy based reality
in a president is obvious any man no
matter how immoral II or illegally he
achieved the Oval Office is still as
Lincoln said President of the United
States clothed with immense power for
the unthinking the uneducated the
unbalanced who sincerely believed him or
who have chosen to as if they have a
menu of realities from which to select a
lie a calumny a slander a preposterous
fiction is automatically less of a lie
less of a colony less of a slander less
of a preposterous fiction just because
he said it thus the flunkies like the
house Intel Chairman newness and the
bottom feeders of Filth like Fox News
and Breitbart and Alex Jones and Mark
Levin line up to endure
and reinforce the lives and thus the
mighty engines of Investigation with
which Congress is clothed or which the
Free Press is clothed is not turned on
the obvious gigantic irrefutable horizon
blocking truth that Trump and Man afford
and stone and Cohen and Kushner and
Flynn and Sessions and Gordon and Paige
and Trump jr. all interacted with the
Russians in some nefarious way great or
small during the campaign and after it
no those investigative engines are
turned instead on a previous president
and something there is no evidence he
did something there was never even a
rumor that he did something that has
been propagated nationally by the
paranoid in chief without any substance
governmental er journalistically a
desperate and manufactured slander
designed as part of a cover-up of true
and traitorous crimes containing exactly
the same amount of probability of truth
as something that would have come to
Donald Trump in a dream that they will
investigate and now not even logic and
motive are still necessary even on the
one in a trillion chance none of it is
criminal
Trump's connection to Russia is
plausible if only because the Russians
wanted a president who would give them a
free hand in Ukraine and elsewhere and
because Trump's desperate ego would let
him pay any price even the freedom of
this country he falsely purports to love
to gain ultimate power for himself but
Trump's Obama claim what is the theory
here what is the motive what is the
purpose as Obama's former speechwriter
jon favreau tweeted barack obama's
master plan one wiretap the opposition
to gather damaging info three say
nothing for let him win five right off
into the sunset it is as nonsensical as
Trump's claim of Democrats enabling
three million illegal votes all of them
for Hillary Clinton and none of them in
the counties wherein 70,000 votes would
have swung the election to her there are
paranoid insane unsupported conspiracy
theories but even they divide into the
good ones and the
bad ones and the man holding the
executive power of this nation cannot
even tell the difference between them he
who has already sold birtherism
conspiracies and vaccination
conspiracies and inauguration crowd
sighs conspiracies and illegal vote
conspiracies and a carnage of immigrant
violence conspiracies and 40%
unemployment conspiracies he has now
sold the last president tapping his
phone and stealing his secrets and doing
nothing with the secrets before the
election conspiracies this is the
immediate danger the active crisis of
fantasy based reality into which Donald
Trump has pushed this nation with his
pedaling of the ludicrous but the true
danger is which insane conspiracy and
which resultant crisis is next
Trump has already sold the gullible the
snake oil that Isis is pouring across
the nation's borders Trump has already
sold the stupid on the falsehood that
immigrants commit virtually all violent
crime and push virtually all drugs when
an immigrant is in fact less likely to
break the law Trump has already sold the
racist and the hateful that a then
sitting president of the United States
is behind the leaks from his
administration and now that he tapped
his phone apparently just for the hell
of it what will Trump try to sell us
next what would stop him from announcing
that there is a terrorist plot and
behind it is a judge he doesn't like or
a newspaper he doesn't like or a senator
he doesn't like or a religion or a race
he doesn't like or a member of your
family he doesn't like what would stop
him from using that immense power to
declare an imminent threat against an
institution a city a state the nation in
whole and this time not merely tweet but
act and closed borders or detained
critics or arrest protesters or suspend
laws and liberties what would stop him
who would stop him his enablers his
cabinet his supporters his political
party his FBI director his conscience
his news sources nothing
would stop him except removal from
office resist peace